all right let's try d4 and now what all
right let's I've played this before to
the Levitsky attack and somebody was
asking asking me when I played this last
time they were like well what if f6 is
played last time I played it was Knight
f6 and I just chopped that night up but
they asked if f6 is played would I throw
my bishop back to d2 I and I said no if
anything comparing d2 and c1 i said i'd
rather go home then go to d2 ah i said
to that question i'd go with Bishop f4
h4 I think I like this
um so let's get the night out I need to
make sure that II five won't be played
with tempo otherwise f6 could turn out
to just be a success
um
well let's get this in and I'll consider
Bishop to hear yeah let's throw that
night in a pin still looking to put a
stop to this advanced now am i okay with
double def ponds the short answer is yes
in the reason why is because now I could
pinpoint this epon castle rookie one
this guy right here is coming under fire
real soon now what do I do with this
night 93-92 f1 g3 like a ray lopez if i
take here the night has to recapture
otherwise this falls or queen side would
be compromised if pond recaptures
let's see
ah do I want to give it my bishop for a
night not so sure about that one I might
want to go all the way home Bishop
Waltons yeah actually bishop f1 well
maybe g3 bishop age three yeah let me do
that let me stay out of the way I don't
know that it's a good idea to even stay
on this diagonal I'm like in g 3 be what
else or maybe this how it's c4 and then
Knight c3 ah that's that's the way to go
put pressure on this pond if I if my
opponent gives up their Center pond this
guy right here on d5 then I'm were able
to recapture my bishop and put pressure
on e6 that I do the rook is already
contributing and then there's going to
be the bishop may be contributing to e6
Knight c3 is definitely going to be the
follow up here and with this move now
there is something that needs to be done
about d5 and that is not easy to do it's
not easy to support it is it it's
unsupportable it is I'm winning that
pond and if there was the capture then
there's this that would have been a
problem spot so I'm just I'm just
getting this guy for free take and I
don't take right away if I take right
away then there's rook captures and then
Queen recaptures and I lose this pond
back I want to be able to win this pawn
and be threatening to win another pond
with a 4 so in other words after ed I do
this move first or do I wait a second
wait a second if I take the rook the
bishop can recapture and the Queen would
be defending the pond I have thoughts of
winning the queen or are still actually
winning this pond with a bishop move to
follow skewering maybe a queen and king
for example playing the rook here is is
threatening Knight takes pawn if i take
the rook the bishop recaptures and then
is going to be in the spot to play to f7
I don't know that for if I really like
that Knight takes rook takes interesting
let's surround the numbers on this man
why can't I think here what's going on
here rook takes rook Bishop takes rook
or Knight takes pawn rook takes for a
queen takes rook let's try it hopefully
my night could be annoying
hmm
well I opponent has about a one-minute
edge and what else ok well now I'm just
up a clear pond that was not the move to
be running with and develop a bishop out
and I could be winning that b7 pun if
the night captures
and come back
and I guess it's going to be I don't
want this night to go anywhere let's put
pressure on this diagonal maybe get to
h7 now and and and and I want c5 now as
soon as this move is played I think and
night getting to see file would be very
good what else less than a minute two
minutes for black
okay i'm not sure what the purpose was
for c6 i guess it allows the Queen to
come out but night c5 is going to just
going to be a giant beast right here as
soon as he gets there hitting everything
hmm ok let's go here right now hitting
the bishop and keep in mind that the
bishop is needed to defend the night not
a good spot to be and so defending the
bishop with the rook isn't is just
losing right away oak recapture that was
with checks a knight takes Bishop and
this is very awkward I think the Queen
has to defend the bishop the bishop goes
back it's me back rank issues for black
and have this that's probably best I
guess huh alright let me make sure the
light square Bishop is off the board and
then copy whole for my king flight
square for my king and it frees up what
does it do it frees up that's losing
because I get the night it's freeing up
I was going to say it's freeing up my
queen from having to defend on f4 so
mopping up phase Bishop b3 rid of the
night and I needs to go and now I could
take up a nice spot right here um I
should probably move faster here
Queen c6 they're low on time as well I'm
on g6 and unless there's a queen trade
I'm crashing through at that point I
have ee8 covered so Queen f6 missed that
mate okay time pressure both ends good
game let's back up hit that rewind
button and flip the board so from your
perspective what is a suggestion I have
the f6 seems awkward I don't know i
think it is maybe a book line i cannot
be certain of it I don't know if it's uh
I actually I don't even know I shouldn't
even be saying that I think it is
because I really just don't know I'm not
pulling any i'm not drawing from
anything it's not even an educated guess
right that I don't know if f6 is even a
move but um i guess if you are going to
run with it and make it work you need to
get an e5 successfully and I don't well
you didn't end up getting it in
successfully right here definitely try
and get that light squared Bishop out
first if you're going to go with e6 next
because he turned out to be a big dummy
he was just kind of stuck behind your
own pond staring at them so consider
getting him out if you're really going
to go with e6 get them out one of these
two how about here actually where we got
here I throw my night out why not right
now how about how about this how about
you're able to now let's say make this e
5 move work let's see how you could do
that Bishop g4 what do I do let's say I
run with the very typical III well guess
what you could play e5 right away
because my night to pinned or maybe
there's something where you just chop my
night and then get an e5 how does that
make f6 work it's awkward having it on
f6 because your night can't play there
but somehow put it to good use and I
think you could do it in this way chop
this night get this Bishop out first and
then play e5 quick suggestion
and I think you'll find yourself in a
much better game also know that this is
a drawback this is this is an asset for
white having doubled pawns the pressure
that I have on the e-file is difficult
to defend against and this pond right
here contributes to control over the e5
square those are my main suggestions
very early on get that light square
Bishop out and think twice before you
actually run forward with trying to
compromise my pawn structure like this
because doubled pawns are not always a
liability in this case they're an asset